[Applause]
you know what you were fantastic
the time has come for the parting of
ways the last Doctor Who episode episode
episode to feature Christopher Eccleston
as the doctor and I'll tell you going
back through series 1 again it makes me
miss him quite a bit
he was really good even when episodes
weren't always great he was pretty much
always spot-on there was only one or two
times that things felt slightly off with
him but for the most part he was there
and and knowing now even though a lot of
the details still haven't really been
made public or I've been talked about
knowing that at the very least the vibe
has been made clear that he wasn't happy
on set and in the shooting conditions
that he was in that he still gave the
performance that he did might you know
props to the guy absolutely I know there
are some Doctor Who fans who like have
an axe to grind with him because they
feel like he has kind of bad mouth to
the show or doesn't honor the legacy you
know in the way that some fans would
like but I I look at the guys output and
I say I think his work speaks for
herself and I think he did a phenomenal
job but let's talk about this last
episode so we're coming off a bad wolf
an episode that I do not like at all
really
so um coming off of that it's yeah it
was always gonna be rough going coming
in off the back of that but we've got
all these Daleks to deal with now the
rent has been established but we also
get the Dalek Emperor I actually really
really really really liked the Dalek
Emperor first of all I love the voice
because you know with the Dalek voice is
iconic but it's also oftentimes kind of
high-pitched and so to get this deep
reverberating Rumble from the Dalek
Emperor oh god I love it and while I do
enjoy late
of the Dalek supreme the various ones
we've seen who have usually gotten a
deeper voice a bit like that there's
something about that first time with
that Emperor it's like whoa man and the
the whole idea is actually quite
interesting that in his preservation and
rebuilding of the Daleks that what he's
created is a little new and a little
different because there's this whole
element of himself as a god and there's
now a self-loathing to the Daleks
because they know somewhere deep down
and back in their minds that they
originated as cells from human beings
which you know that's not Dalek that's
not pure that's gonna bring a level of
self-hatred and in a way it makes me a
little bit sad that this batch of Daleks
was pretty much gone no not pretty much
is that they're gone at the end of this
and I feel like there was some some
mileage to be gotten out of digging into
how they are new and different and
distinct from the Daleks that the doctor
was actually fighting during the time
war or that we've seen up here
previously and I kind of wish they'd
done that they didn't you know road not
traveled but I like I like that that all
works for me
the the whole thing okay so the whole
bad wolf thing is something I have gone
back and forth and been kind of mixed on
so I feel this is this is very much you
know a left field
waitwhat ending and resolution now I do
I'm not I know that seeds were planted
for this because we had the bad wolf
recurring across the series and we
established the heart of the TARDIS in
boomtown but at the same time I don't
think there's any I think I still think
it's a big leap from the things that
were established to what we got we just
had a term showing up that was not
really pointed out by the show until two
episodes prior to this and
we had the heart of the TARDIS something
not established again until two episodes
prior to this which there was nothing
about boomtown would make you think Oh
Rose will be able to absorb that and
save the day some Dao now I I think
better on it now parched partially
because honestly thanks to Moffat
because I really one of the things I
really love about Dave the doctor is the
bad wolf entity as we see it there
played again by pills by Billy Piper and
I really like sort of establishing this
as not just something created in the
moment by this fusion of the time vortex
into rose but something that actually
exists possibly in a way outside of time
and space that inhabited her for a
little bit I like that idea better and
that is basically a retcon from Moffat
and the it honestly it does kind of
improve my opinion about this what in
some of the supporting cast what happens
is with Lynda I think is is is quite sad
and I think the sadness for that is
built to nicely I think they did a good
job endearing her quickly and making her
death feel like a legitimate loss in
some way and Jackie and Mickey have so
Jackie especially this is one of her
better appearances especially early on
series one she graded on me a bit so
this is this is one of her better
appearances and I do quite like the way
that Rose connects with her bringing up
Pete and her having been the girl who
was there when when he was dying and
there was someone there with him and I
like how you know Jackie bases needs to
leave and process that and you know
comes back and makes the extra effort to
help I do think the the goodbyes from
dot from the doctor because he
effectively gets to I think those are
the highlights and those I mean those
are touching moments firstly when he you
know when the whole would the hologram
you know saying that things went bad
you're gonna live I'm probably not have
a good life live a good life for me and
this is also one of the few times where
I feel like the the whole element of
companions and you know how do you live
a normal life after traveling with the
doctor I feel like this is one of a few
times that that plays well it's a
concept that I don't think is a bad idea
and I think it's it's it plays some
interesting it plays an interesting part
here and and there's some ideas worth
exploring there it works especially well
with Rose given how young she is because
you know she's she's basically had her
mind blown at a young age and I was like
well what am I supposed to do now like
that makes a lot of sense to me I don't
like that later on though they'll kind
of retcon and imply that it's like this
for every companion when they start
traveling with the doctor because they
end up implying that with Sarah Jane
later on when she gets reintroduced into
the show and you know they kind with the
way Martha came back it kind of seems
like a bit of a similar thing and I
don't I don't I like this idea I don't
like this idea being blanketed across
the campaign's as a whole which I feel
like in some ways the show kind of did
but taking it in isolation it's it's
it's well done here and certainly as a
motivator for pushing rose to do the
most extreme thing that you can think of
to try and get back that all works and
then there's the doctor's proper goodbye
you know at the end and I really like
this regeneration I'm one of these days
I'm gonna rank the regenerations I just
need to figure out if I'm gonna rank
regenerate the regeneration moments or
regeneration stories I need to fear how
I'm gonna do that but I do like this for
generation a lot it it hits the note of
giving him a farewell of acknowledging
the loss to Rose and to us as an
audience without getting really
self-indulgent with it which the series
kinda has since this I think this is the
right amount of time he you know he
knows what's going on he tries to make
light of it he tries to explain it and
then it's just gonna happen so I like
all that I think that works well I don't
love it didn't I didn't think much on it
one way or the other on first viewing
but it does bother me a little bit that
hid the way he absorbs the time vortex
out of roses through a kiss I don't love
that like I don't think it's necessary
like it's this becomes one of those
things where yes they justify it in
terms of like okay well that's where
it's gonna come from then he may he
connects with her that way so like you
can say oh but it's not a romantic kiss
because time vortex absorption but I
just I don't I wish they had done it
literally any other way like stare into
her eyes and have it go into his eyes
it's just something I don't love that
it's this tender kiss be partly because
with this doctor specifically I've said
this before I've never gotten that vibe
of him and Rose like especially not from
him to her which you know being that
he's the one that initiates this kiss
it's it's a weird moment I don't like I
don't have a problem with with
logistically what's going on in the
scene I just don't like the manner in
which it happens I don't think it helps
I don't think it adds anything really so
you know I've got little nitpicks like
that and and I and you know there is a
suddenness to the way Rose just
dissolves of all the Daleks that you
know and people can debate how much of a
deus ex machina this is or isn't because
you know the elements are set up to some
degree ahead of time but what I don't
like about it is is how it removes so
many of the consequences of what came
and remove so many the baby I don't like
how
clean it makes it like yes at least your
regeneration but you know the the thing
that bugs me about a fair number of the
series finales the FIR doctor for modern
era Doctor Who is how they ultimately
resolved by undoing whatever the threat
would like completely undoing it in this
case the of the Daleks now these Daleks
literally no longer exist so you know
there's that and I won't go into it with
the other stuff but I think it happens
with a with a fair number of them though
they're like single they'll single out
like a specific thing like oh well it'll
have consequences to this character or
like okay but if you're gonna have
personal stakes and personal
consequences why do you have to blow up
the threat so big that the only way to
resolve it without completely rewriting
the entire way the show is gonna work
moving forward it is to erase it like if
you're gonna have personal stakes then
have that have a slightly smaller scale
threat then it doesn't need to be that
big if your true story is Hugh I don't
know I don't even know if I'm expressing
that correctly again it's not
necessarily a problem with this episode
but I'm sort of I'm getting ahead of
myself because it's a pattern that I
have a problem with in Doctor Who
because you know this and then doomsday
oh these Cybermen came through oh don't
worry now they're all gone or in last of
the Timelords oh these things invaded
earth oh don't worry they're now
completely gone in the entire year they
took over the world is erased from
history it never happened you know all
this stuff just gets completely undone
and that's it's hard for me to get
invested in the world ending stakes when
there are no real lasting consequences
on a global scale if you're gonna
threaten the world it should affect the
world and ultimately if it doesn't maybe
you didn't need to threaten the world
you only needed to threaten the
characters that you actually had get
impacted and the characters do get
impacted obviously well we'll pick up
with Jack later on down the line to see
how things rolled out for him
but Rose has now got to contend with the
new doctor the doctor himself just
regenerate so you know there are
consequences I just don't know if it was
necessary to scale up the threat as big
as it did and I do think in some ways it
contributes to the weakening of the
Daleks as a threat because you know
again you can justify it with the nature
of what the bad wolf is and what is
capable of as to how she defeated them
so easily but if that still fleet of
Daleks effectively wiped out with like a
fan oh snap so I think long-term it
probably still cause some issues but I'm
sort of I'm starting to bring in the
baggage of what I know become recurring
things across the show narrowing it down
to this this is this is really good this
is a really good solid farewell to this
doctor like to the point that I don't
even mind that it's set on that it's
located on a reused set because because
they have barely they had to milk
satellite 5 - absolute death so yeah
yeah for as much as I as I've now spent
complaining going yeah but I do really
like this Eccleston nails it Rose cells
the heck out of it and and I like the
Dalek Emperor a quite a bit I think he's
inherently highly intimidating so the
parting of ways what are your thoughts
on it whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about a
whole bunch of stuff that you can do
because there's buttons and there's
links including a link to my patreon if
you feel generous if you don't don't
worry about it there's other links you
can check out but if you don't even want
to do that
don't sweat it because at the end of the
day you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]